neil young
neil young aged canadian hippie
well-known whiner of such songs as
helpless helpless old man take a look at
my life he's you know he's been around
for a very long time
not quite as popular now as he once was
looks crazier than ever neil young
is demanding
that spotify make a choice
it's either him
or rogan
because neil young believes
that joe rogan is spreading fake news
about the vaccines this is very very
dangerous and so neil young says i'm
going to have you take my music off if
you don't you it's remember him
it's not even sort of like a whoa boy
i'm not i'm not it's not quite
it's not my best neil young impression
but it's not that far off he says
i'll do this in my ordinary voice i am
doing this because spotify is spreading
fake information about vaccines
potentially causing death to those who
believe the disinformation being spread
by them please act on this immediately
today and keep me informed of the time
schedule i want spotify
to
know today that i want all my music off
their platform they have rogan or young
not both
it's a really tough choice
really tough choice for spotify
do you go with a whiny old hippie who
hasn't been particularly relevant since
the 70s or the most popular broadcaster
in the entire world
who do you pick
do you pick
this angry guy with admittedly like
seven or eight hit songs more maybe more
maybe that's not fair with a you know
dozen or so really popular songs
or joe rogan the single most popular man
with a microphone on planet earth right
now
neil young i'm sure makes spotify
several hundred dollars a month
and joe rogan brings them in gazillions
of dollars a minute
i suspect they're gonna go with rogan
that's what i would guess
part of the reason they should go with
rogan is that neil young is just wrong
on the merits here
joe rogan has spread much much much less
scientific misinformation about kovid
then has dr fauci then has rachelle
wolenski then has joe biden
all of those people
spread
misinformation
about
the masks about the vaccines about the
virulence of the virus about the risk of
the virus to other people about the
transmissibility about all of it
and the way i know that they've spread
misinformation
is that they have held
contradictory sides of all of those
issues
don't wear the masks they don't work do
wear the masks you need to wear them the
vaccines stop infection and transmission
the vaccines don't stop infection and
transmission the vaccines
are totally safe the vaccines actually
have some side effects and we're gonna
pause some of the vaccines sometimes the
cloth masks
do work right they kept that one up from
the first and but actually the cloth
masks don't really do very much they're
nothing but a facial decoration that's
what the cnn medical analyst said on and
on and on and on and on
joe rogan much more consistent much less
misinformation than all of that
and the procedure is preposterous
for him to say it's it's him or me one
an important lesson in politics is know
your leverage no your leverage buddy
ain't nobody going to be missing neil
young i actually kind of like neil young
songs
okay i guess i won't listen to them now
okay that's not not a huge loss
plus i can listen to clapton and van
morrison who have a decent head on their
shoulders no one wants to cut corners on
what's important and few things matter
more than a good night's rest bowlin
branch's signature sheets feel so soft
and light you'll forget you're not
actually sleeping on a cloud and they're
sustainably made for uncompromising
quality from field to factory i
absolutely love bowling branch i have
been using them for years
the only reason i didn't want to upgrade
my bed from a queen to a king was i was
afraid i wouldn't get more bolon branch
sheets and then i just did i just
they're just so wonderful they're a
great i've bought
many
versions of the bowling brand sheets
their signature hemmed sheets from
bowling branch are a best seller for a
reason
buttery soft lightweight organic cotton
in a classic sateen weave for sheets
that not only start out soft they get
softer over time
they're really terrific 100 organic
cotton 30-day risk-free trial free
shipping and returns experience the best
sheets you've ever felt at
bowlingbranch.com get 15 off your first
set of sheets when you use promo code
michael at checkout that's bowlin branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d branch dot com promo code
michael i'm glad you like that clip i
i'm glad you showed up now if you want
to show up for more clips you got to
ring the bell subscribe get those
notifications
i hope you get the notifications even
once you ring that bell if you don't
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your audio podcasts type in do to do the
michael knowles show doo doo doo
subscribe leave a five star review boom
boom boom doo doo hack the mainframe
you're all good we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you